Developers, start Google
App Engine.
It's time to show the world
what you've got.
We all have big ideas, but
isn't turning them into
reality what really
sets us apart?
This November, we're asking
you and other creative
developers around the world
to enter the Google Cloud
Platform Developer Challenge
with an app you build using
Google App Engine.
Earn bonus points for
integrating the Google Maps,
YouTube, and Google+
sign in APIs.
Feel like your app will
change the world?
Enter it into the enterprise and
small business solutions,
education, and not-for-profit
category.
Want to make the world a
more exciting place?
Check out our second category
for social, personal
productivity, games,
and fun apps.
So what's in it for you besides
the satisfaction of
designing the next killer app
with Google Cloud Platform?
Global recognition as
a groundbreaking
developer, for one thing.
But also some really cool
prizes, including Android
devices, the ability to share
ideas with other talented
developers at a Google
conference, and cash prizes of
up to $20,000.
To get started, visit the
Google Cloud Platform
Developer Challenge website
for more details.
Follow the hashtag #gcdc on
Google+, then start hacking.
So what are you waiting for?
Apps are due November 21.
We're looking forward to
watching you transform your
best ideas into reality.